- I'm after yours.
- Oh my God! I'm after yours.
We should tradesies after the show.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Well, I'm gonna start
with congratulations.
New son, right?
- Yes. Thank you very much.
Yes. Six months old.
- [Kelly] How? Six months?
Oh, are you sleeping?
- More... Yeah.
Like he's doing okay.
He's sleeping more than we are.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(all laugh)
- So you have a two year old, right?
- [Lindsay] Yes.
- So do you do Halloween?
Do y'all get all done up?
I love Halloween.
- Well as someone who
dresses up for a living,
it's not like my favorite
thing to put on a costume,
but of course, like,
my daughter really
wanted us to do "Frozen."
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh!
- [Lindsay] So, she's Anna
and I am gonna be Elsa
and my partner's gonna be Kristoff.
And so that's fun.
She has no idea that Uncle
Jonathan is Kristoff.
That'll be mind blowing when
she figures that out but...
- Oh my God. Yeah, she'd lose it.
- [Lindsay] I know.
- It is funny when...
because my kids saw an
animated thing that I did
and they were like, it broke the wall.
- [Lindsay] Oh God!
- It was kind of intensely sad.
- [Daniel] Oh no.
- Yeah. Yeah.
They saw me in this
movie called "Ugly Dolls"
and they were like, "We
don't understand," but like,
and I was like, "Well,
you know, like Elsa,
like, you know, like she's a real person,"
And they were like, "What?"
And I was like, "Oh my God!"
- [Daniel] "Oh no.
What have I ruined?"
- I felt like a horrible human.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] But, you know,
it was gonna happen
sooner or later.
- I do that to kids on
like a regular basis
when they're like, "It's Harry,"
and I'm like, "I'm sorry."
They're like, "You're
old now. What happened?"
(all laugh)
- So that was what's so funny.
My daughter was obsessed with Chris Martin
for, like, I mean years.
And she always watched the "Yellow" video,
but he's younger.
It's his first single.
And so whenever she saw him,
she's like, "Well, he looks different."
I go, "Well, we age, honey."
But yeah.
Okay. Enough about kids.
So I have to get to this.
I heard that you went to
Beyonce's Renaissance tour.
Was it four times?
Four times.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I have a question.
I haven't been...
So, is it like "O" like you can keep going
and you see something new?
Like, you know the "O" in Vegas?
- [Jonathan] Yes, yes.
I would say... I mean, I haven't seen "O."
- [Kelly] Oh, you can...
I can go again and see something...
- [Jonathan] You could, yeah.
I'm sure it's amazing.
- [Kelly] Look at you!
- [Jonathan] That's me
at Beyonce with Jenny T.
- [Kelly] You whipped your hair.
- [Jonathan] Yes.
That's me and Jenny T.
- [Kelly] You look like Patrick Swayze
in "Dirty Dancing" right
now. What's happening?
- [Jonathan] You just made my life.
(Lindsay and Daniel laugh)
- [Kelly] That is really what you..
like, with your tank and you're sweaty
and the little curl.
It was like nice. Okay, okay.
- [Jonathan] I mean, he is God.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. You really can go again and again.
I've already got tickets of...
I've got them for these two.
If they're joining me
or not, I don't know.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- On the 1st of December,
when the movie comes out,
the concert movie of Beyonce
is coming out. The film.
- Oh my God!
- For after our show that Friday night.
- I'm not doing anything after
the show. Are you insane?
- I'm not either. We have children.
- You might though. You might.
I might get you to go.
- [Kelly] I am so these people.
I'm like, "I'm tired."
- [Daniel] For Beyonce?
- [Jonathan] Yes. But for
Beyonce it's different.
And the concert...and I...
It's transcendent.
It's a transcendent experience.
- [Kelly] I love that.
It's amazing to be in a concert like that.
- Before we did this, we
do eight shows a week.
It's a lot of the same show every night
of Merrily We Roll Along.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And watching Beyonce,
all the four times that I saw it
all the times that I
watched her on YouTube
in all the other cities...
- I love you so much.
- [Jonathan] Like she
brought it to every city,
no matter which country, which city.
It was always new.
She was always in a
different outfit and...
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- [Jonathan] It inspired
me for the run of our show,
that every time you perform live,
there's new people out there.
You have to bring everything you've got.
So it was a real source of inspiration.
I'm clearly passionate.
- You have a poster of her in your room.
- I have. Yes.
Krystal Joy Brown, who
plays Gussie in our show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- As a gift got me the Renaissance poster
and she's there in the dressing room.
- She's there every day.
- Part of the show.
- I look at her every day.
- So I had this experience with you too.
I saw 'em at Madison Square Garden and
I left half wanting to quit music.
But, the other half of
me was so inspired and
it is... It does...
It's like, man, they've been doing this
for so long and it's such,
it renews like a certain
passion inside you.
- [Jonathan] Yes. Completely.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I love that for you.
Have you ever seen
anybody that many times?
- No.
- [Lindsay] No.
- [Kelly] No?
- No.
- [Kelly] Is there someone you would see?
(Kelly laughing)
Is there someone you think you would,
like, if you had the
time and no babies or...
- I mean, yeah, there's
definitely bands that like,
but I don't think anyone like,
the hold steady anyone.
Nobody.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh, you're like you...
- So I'm like, yeah, there's definitely,
I love trying new stiff...
but like there's
definitely people I would.
But not...probably four times
is stretching it though?
Is there anyone you would say that much?
- I don't know.
Maybe like Barbra Streisand.
- [Kelly] Like, oh, I've never seen her.
- Me neither.
I would die to see her.
We should go...
- If she comes to New
York, we are gonna go.
- [Lindsay] Yep. We're gonna go.
- [Kelly] You think I'm
kidding, but I'm not.
- No. I'm serious. I'm like...
- [Kelly] I don't feel
like she does shows though.
- I don't know.
I'm just saying like,
if we put it out in the universe.
- [Kelly] Did you see the thing she did,
the music and Memories thing she did
at like Netflix or something?
It was some kind of thing.
Oh my! I'm weeping.
- [Jonathan] Yeah, she did it in Brooklyn.
This concert.
(Kelly gasps)
- Yeah and...
- And her new book's about to come out.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] I want her on the show.
I was like, wait.
I was like, we share a birthday.
I love you.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] Do I get any points there?
- Wait, the song I picked for you
for your Spotify playlist,
is a Barbra song.
It's an obscure Barbra song.
- [Kelly] How obscure?
What's it called?
Oh, you're not gonna tell me.
- It's called Napoleon.
- [Kelly] Oh, I don't know that one.
- [Kelly] I feel like there's a complex,
I feel like is this a fun song?
'cause you could go a lot
of ways with Napoleon.
- [Jonathan] It's a very fun song.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay. Okay.
Did y'all know each other
before you got on stage?
'cause I feel like you,
even the voice coaches
they have us have like a dinner
or get together for drinks or something.
If you've never met each other
and they have us kind
of you know, hang out.
- That would've been nice.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, you did...
Was the first day just... Oh!
- No, we've known each
other for a long time.
- Yeah.
- But you know, we knew
we were doing this for,
I don't know, a year or something.
So we all... We got each other's info
and started sending video text messages
back and forth to get to know each other.
- [Daniel] Which I was
slightly stressed out by,
because these guys send like,
very relaxed, natural
sort of 2-3 minute videos
giving an update.
And I was always just watching them.
And when I would try and send back,
I would have to restart
it like three times,
'cause I'm like, oh,
I'm saying "um" an "ah too much.
Or I'm saying (indistinct)
(all laughing)
- And then they would...
I would feel like I had to make notes and
just like, what everything did they say
in their videos that I...
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- [Daniel] I have become
more relaxed about it
since then. Thank God.
- [Kelly] Good for you.
- Yeah. It's real growth.
Thank you.
(all laughing)
- [Jonathan] You've great video.
- [Daniel] I do now. Thank you.
- [Jonathan] Great video.
- [Kelly] Well he worked on them.
They should be pretty good.
(all laughing)
- I've been. Yeah. Rehearsing apparently.
(audience cheering)
- I recently moved here.
I love working here. Thank you.
But what do y'all like about working here?
Do you like it?
Do you like living here and working here?
- Oh, I mean, anytime I
get to work in New York
it's kind of the dream.
Like I live here most of the time.
I mean, pretty much.
Yeah. I live here now, basically.
I think I can say that.
And yeah, anytime I get to also work here
and just like come home
to my place at the end of the day
and be in the, you know West Village.
It's awesome. I love this city.
So, I feel really lucky
to be able to live here.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And raising kids here is kind of fun!
- It's amazing!
- [Kelly] I didn't
think that would happen.
- [Lindsay] There's much for them here.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Lindsay] 'cause I was
living in LA too for a while
and came back here for this and Oh my God!
Like the parks and the museums
and taking her, you know
on the bus and on the
subway, like, it's so fun.
We just, we have such a
full life here with kids.
It's fantastic.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Do you love it?
- Obsessed. I love it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Jonathan] I put on my bike helmet.
I get on my bicycle.
- [Kelly] You're one
of those brave people.
- [Lindsay] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I haven't done that yet.
- [Jonathan] It's so...
I recommend maybe in Central Park first
before you move to the streets.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I have a bike coming and I just...
I also see the ER in my future.
I just, I don't know.
- [Jonathan] Yeah, yeah yeah.
- [Kelly] I just feel like,
people can drive crazy here little bit.
- [Lindsay] Yes.
- [Daniel] Yeah.
- [Jonathan] Yeah. It's
intense in those bike lanes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it's also beautiful and incredible
and riding the bike to the theater.
My favorite thing about New
York is the live theater,
that like eight times a week,
there's all of these people
in this like, small area of New
York performing these plays.
It's such a special place.
- [Kelly] That's an amazing
way to look at it too.
Yeah. And just, it's
not gonna last forever.
That show's gonna leave...
So it's like, you wanna catch it like,
the energy of that is pretty magical.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Well explain to everybody
if that doesn't know
Merrily We Roll Along.
What is it about?
Who wants time go?
- [Jonathan] Am I taking this one?
- [Daniel] Jonathan's got this one.
- You were all like, "Not me."
- [Lindsay] Yes.
- [Jonathan] So, Merrily We Roll Along,
is a story of three friends,
a friendship that spans 20 years,
but it's a musical.
Music and lyrics by Stephen Sondheim,
incredible composer of Into the Woods
and Sunday in the Park with George.
And the unique thing, or
one of the unique things
about the show is that it's
about a 20 year friendship,
but it's told backwards.
So it starts at the end of the friendship
and goes all the way back
to the beginning when they first met.
- [Kelly] And the music is amazing.
Sondheim is amazing.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] So, I know I haven't seen it.
My executive producers like, get to this.
I'm just, my kids' just got in school
and there's all these parent-teacher.
Gosh. So I haven't been able to catch yet.
- [Daniel] Don't worry.
It's fine. It's cool.
Don't worry. Thank you.
- [Kelly] I know. But
there's so many shows.
I have a list with my
girlfriends for our night...
We have one night at a week.
- [Daniel] When you come
let us know. No pressure.
- [Kelly] No. I'm not gonna let you know,
because you're like me.
- [Daniel] Oh yeah.
- You don't like to know when people come.
- Let us know.
- [Kelly] I don't either.
- They won't tell me. I'll find out later.
Then, that's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay. We are identical in this.
'cause I don't like when people tell me
people are at my show because I will,
one, think about it the whole time
and then I will search for them.
- [Daniel] Yes.
- [Jonathan and Lindsay] Oh!
- I was told recently,
there was a moment like,
three weeks ago where Meryl Streep
was supposed to be coming
to the show for the night.
- [Kelly] You never tell someone,
Meryl Streep is coming.
- Right.
And I accidentally found
out and then I was like,
she didn't end up coming.
I think she had something else to do.
- Oh my gosh!
- [Daniel] She's a busy woman.
But like, I for the whole time..
'cause that's the thing
when if I know that like an anonymous
famous person is in the
crowd, I'm fine with it.
As soon as I know specifically who it is
I keep thinking like, "Oh God, you know,
Robert De Niro is out there thinking...
watching my acting tonight."
That's a terrifying thought.
But he is a psychopath.
- Yeah.
- And he likes knowing.
- He loves to know.
- You're opposite.
- [Jonathan] I love to know.
- Yep.
- I love to know.
When I was doing Hamilton with Lin,
we shared a dressing room
and I used to be like,
I don't know if I like to know or not
but Lin obsessively wanted to know
who was in the audience
and it would bring him so much joy
and it would infuse
his performance with...
- [Kelly] Well, he used it.
- [Jonathan] He used it.
So like when Eminem was there,
who's like one of his rap heroes,
he was like rapping in
a slightly harder way.
When Meryl was there,
we were all giving like,
very acted performances of Hamilton.
- [Kelly] Sophie's choice level.
- [Jonathan] Yes. It was very...
We were like suddenly
conscious of everything
that we were doing with our hands.
(all laughing)
- [Jonathan] That's like
the vibe I feel when...
- [Kelly] I'm completely him. No.
- [Jonathan] You are
like, you as well. Right.
- [Kelly] Do you like to know?
- I'm kind of in the middle.
Like if I find out, I
mean, and the truth is like
at Merrily we've had so
many people come now..
- [Kelly] Well that's good.
Then it becomes normal.
- [Lindsay] It kind of has
started to become normal.
But I used to be like him and be like,
"Don't tell me" or I'll be the entire
show thinking how bad I am.
- [Daniel] Yeah. We all
thought Tom Hanks was there
the other day. He was not.
- I know.
- We've had it confirmed.
It was not him.
There's a guy who looks a lot like him
who seeing shows in New York.
- [Kelly] Doppelganger.